[Music]  rihanna is living her best life in  barbados the 29 year old really misses  an opportunity to party at the Caribbean  islands crop / festival but this year  was one for the books  RiRi took to Instagram over the weekend  to show off her sexy barely-there  costume intricately beaded string bikini  turquoise wig giant colorful feathers  jewels and all giving off some serious  Victoria's Secret Angel vibes some a  heavy work work work work work work the  work singer went live from the  celebrations could do Mint Day parade  taking in the route from aboard a truck  [Music]  it seems the crowd just couldn't get  enough and neither can we  [Music]